Yes. Well it was. What we tried to do was keep a change of the drug laws. On the agenda. And.
Try and confront society with that. My stand popular fact that it was the.
The prohibition of these substances which were creating a great deal of the problems that we had in this society.
It was a pretty frustrating task. I became aware of the degree of paranoia that exists in the tan. In this area.
Most hassles would have one member. Has been. Wife love a son or daughter.
Friend cousin relative who probably use pot in some degree. And with the attention that had been focused on named and.
Big rides helicopter rides. Destroy type missions. That were regular part of life here. People be.
Became extremely afraid to express their opinion.
And that was probably the most significant thing that i found was the impact that the drug lords were having on society
in that way. People were more prepared to be. Acquiescent. About the laws.
Rather than to challenge them in the hope that they wouldn't stand up in the background scenery.
And that really hasn't changed a great deal. Although there are more and more people.
These days prepared to make a statement publicly about the drug lords. Not really elected. Well i.
In ninety ninety one i stood as an independent candidate on a drug reform ticket in the state parliament.
There's a campaign that i ran pretty much by myself. And it was an opportunity to playa belair in politics. Given that.
It was just really a one person campaign a two and a half thousand votes that i got it wasn't too bad at all.
And i did indicate. To some extent the feeling that was he of the people i voted i ran on a campaign of.
Viking is anonymous. He was a chance to put down your opinion.
And for one one his single issue campaign and it works well. But the problem about the problem that i say that.
Came as a consequence of. My actions is that it has tended to make the the anti drug lobby.
Less likely to stand up and do things. Whilst at the same time. The negative consequences. Of prohibition. Continue.
And so they are largely on checked.
This to me is the challenge of the alternative society of the name and society is somehow rather. Setting to apply.
The fact is in society. That work to. Sorting out these problems. In such a why.
As the community itself and the people within the community.
I mean pallid that they are i built to realize that they can affect shines.
The marijuana laws seem a bit like the work week chink in the.
Because they saw the light and laid problematic lor's there they are laws that don't hold up to scrutiny in any why.
It seemed like. This was a why that. The whole of society. Could be challenged. But.
Difficult really is difficult go and i ran yeah i was part of that campaign. Nimbin. Did. Create it.
The options are available here in him and. Allowed me to campaign in. Pretty many creative why.
One of the wise was the. Advertising on television a local media organization offered to do. Ads for me. Program them.
Or range for them to be programmed in. And that was a bit of a first for. Well it was a first for them.
And it was a first for a local television. Op in this area. You know much else i can cite at it really.
No i don't know that there's been marijuana campaign or marijuana.
The campaign as you know their electorates another election on. But this was the first time that. There's been a local.
Marijuana party. Top campaign run up here.
The elections were great because i did offered that opportunity for a focus on an issue.
I ran a very much a sort of barefoot politician campaign running without a great deal of funds
and we had a great deal of. Visible. Upfront support. You know terms of people.
You know i had nobody stuffing polling booths was very difficult to get people to make any sort of commitment.
In which they publicly committed themselves for drug reform. Or drug law reform.
The degree of paranoia that was he surprised me. Didn't shake my faith in the in the night or the name in community.
It made me aware of just the pressures that people around and made me say. Just how much of a backbone marijuana.
Is to the economy here. And and made me realize that any chinese that i did try and institute.
Eufaula as i will to be successful in bringing a bed to china
and you would have severely affected the laws of a lot of people saw it.
Of being caught on that sort of dilemma between keeping people here. In a sustainable. Income.
And yet at the same time trying to eliminate those negative aspects of it. If marijuana was sold on a cook.
Through a growing cooperative basis. Marketed by a local organization the did pay taxes back into the community.
Not back into the states and federal communities but back into the libel community.
Then we'd have a lot of the a lot of the negative effects of the marijuana tried would be diminished a lot of the
imperatives that are there in the marijuana try the need for people to. Then an encounter.
To try and paint it to their consumption does are as. The degree of hypocrisy that was in society.
Kids would find it very difficult here because they were saying their parents smoking pot.
Selling pot in a lot of cases. And yet. Having to. Publicly present a different persona.
And at the same time telling their kids to keep away from drugs.
It only really served to make the situation worse the kids were getting into drugs. And marijuana. But also alcohol.
And every now and again some of the local kids would resort to using chemical substances. But in a lot of cases.
My experience shows me that those people who are more inclined towards getting into things like heroin was who really
feel a lot of pain in society whether that's from broken homes drum. Brutal pay.
From being in allow a socio economic situations. I don't believe that the. That the fact that marijuana is illegal.
And that people use it. Lead people on to hero and use.
I believe that people get into hero and used to try and only unite the pine. That they feel in their laws.
And just like the sly drug dealers. And the brothels. Went to the gulch fields. In the fifty's in ballarat.
In the gulf field of the gulf eels in australia. And pride on the miners. To do the. Heroin dealers.
Come to name them and use the local flight large flutings a man of.
Of money that's there as a source of guying to them in return for heroin. With my own kids smoking pot.
Was one of those things that i tried not to encourage. And it came as a bit of i. Shock the first time that i fand.
My oldest daughter was smoking. And it made me realise just what my own. Real aspirations were and my and.
Free wheeling attitude. Or just what my freewheeling attitude was really worth. In relation to. Drugs.
Have subsequently modified this approach. Adam my children. Three out of the four smoke.
And basically they cope with it reasonably well and. I myself wouldn't. Promote the use of marijuana by anybody.
Or for anybody. But at the same time i can't put down people who do smoke. So i've had to take.
For myself part of the responsibility for setting this particular example. I've also tried to educate them.
Into what i consider to be an advocate of smoking. You don't rip off your friends. Well you don't rip off anybody.
If you're going to provide. Marijuana it's possible that everyone can provide it and so.
So encourage them to grow their own. To look upon it. In that sacramental why that marijuana really is. For instance.
In traditional societies. Substances that change consciousness have always had a place but the places.
Being well defined within society. They generally have a particular outcome they guarded. The people who god.
Are experienced. Over a long period of learning in how to deal with the effects of the consciousness check. Changing.
Substance. What we've done in our society is we've dropped right away from the adage. There's no.
Cultural controls at all on how the. Consciousness changing drugs are used in society. So they used randomly.
They use walls only.
They used you know why that is more to a particular immediate gratification rather than seen in the context of a growth
and as a means of. But handling society and investigating deeper truths that exist within society.
A lot of people do come to niman with. Probably a slightly incorrect view of what newman is going to be like.
Because the mainstream society generally doesn't allow for a great deal of. You know personal communication.
Randomly amongst people. People come here looking for thanks and. Community interaction.
A sense of being important in themselves. And a lot of them don't find it here.
Ultimately it's all within themselves it's all within ourselves this capability to create a new society.
Along the the y. That we want to advance and much by. What's being fed into us by society in the past.
That we are limited in what we are able to actually achieve. A lot of the communities around here.
If you view it dispassionately you'll find that the.
Just has and states where people don't necessarily have a great deal of contact with their neighbors with a community.
They buy a share in a lot of cases that's just a predetermine a lot and.
They build their houses they build a gallons you know why that's quite similar to the suburban dream.
That has grabbed them. Even though that i realize that when they come here they still vann by this suburban dream.
But i really like what timothy leary. Said about the decline of the flower children.
The flower children may be gone but. They've spread this.
And that's when the seeds take root that we'll see the real flaring of the new society.
I tend to think that that that's happening more and more i see a china. That's coming about.
You know a lot of the young people particularly the young people here in name and. As they grow.
And it almost parallels the growth of the name and. Alternative society itself. The twenty years. I'll always.
Is a society barely out of adolescence. There's a lot of ground to do.
There's a lot of maturing a lot of wisdom to to get a lot of implementing of what we've learned to nasa saudi.
It's happening.
It's happening all the time that five years ago there wasn't environments
and there hasn't been a lot of the organizations run by pat company hadn't congealed into an actual working group and.
A lot of the. Health networks the support networks that exist here.
The holes that have been built on the communities the community consultation processes that have come more
and more into play. To me are evidence. All of the alternative society. Actually getting its act together.
Bringing the lessons from what they've learned. On the home communities. Into the public life of name and. And women.
Is benefiting. Substantially from the experiences of these new settlers. But like everywhere.
Once a society starts to flourish.
You do also get an attraction by a lot of people who see an active social cultural life going down.
Visible in the streets. A lifestyle that. Can attract them as. Holding the k.
To their own personal in a to them but the reality. Still is very much of an emerging society.
It's frustrating for a lot of people who do come here. With a lot of ney's or. With a lot of emotional needs.
Mental disturbance. Well look it's frustrating for a lot of people who come here with or seeking an emotional.
Answer to the things that are provided within the dominant society.
And they come here and find that people are still basically the same people.
It's like
when you made somebody famous by sickly they're still the same person that probably got a bit of breakfast dangling on
the front of the issue. The human i mean this is. One of the lessons that is really good to learn here that.
That if you want. This ideal society. You have to sort of dredge it out from within yourself. Find it.
Find that sense of strength and courage that. That is there. And just go for.
We've got everything to lose at the moment. Society is just hanging on the edge. And nieman to may.
Has that capability to create some state of hills. If you have the whole society. Affected by disease.
Then it means the disease. Is able to grow and spread.
In order to can direct that you have to create some sort of pocket of health. That will grow and spread.
Affect the areas around it. Because an immense connotations. All of. An alternative. Visionary prophetic society.
It seems to me that we've got the groundwork set in place here. To create some element of society ill health.
And from that. If we can just hang on long enough. Then the chinese will happen will be able to spread. What.
We've learnt. Altena to the rest of society. You know.
When you look at what i currently in the know what do i hope that. What i when i look at the kids around this area.
What on likely to say. Is what i'm likely to see when i look at the kids in this area.
Are the lessons already learnt that. Way their parents took a great deal of time to learn. Sometimes in about thirty s.
Forty's fifty's. We've still going through the pine. Of experiencing. Things that are being kept from us.
With kids to die. In him and.
They tend to be much more mature experienced in a lot of the things that were never talked about.
As part of their generation. I seem to be able to cope with. China a lot better.
I seem to be more likely to be communal to be. Supporting of each other they tend to go through a in a lot of cases.
Despair frustration. Just like most other kids. But for the ones who are growing up here.
I'm really impressed with the why that they actually do. Seem to find a path. At some point.
Which becomes really solid. Because it's young it has that energy. That's able to achieve things.
I got a great deal of hope in the future. When i look at. The kids that i've grown up with here.